I was welcomed back welcomed back from
my vacation last week to yet another day
of massive stock market crashes on
Friday my mutual fund account looking
very very ugly and at first I wasn't
sure what had caused it because I wasn't
following the news last week since we
were on break the Dow was down another
more than 600 points the NASDAQ and S&P
500 and the Russell 2000 all down the
same or more on a percentage basis and
then on my flight home
I started catching up on news getting
ready for the week of shows and realized
ho yeah
a Donald Trump once again scaling up the
trade war and straight-up tweeting
fascistic threats about controlling
American companies and once again stocks
are taking a dive Donald Trump yes
putting even more self-destructive
tariffs on China but before doing that
take a look at what the President of the
United States tweeted quote our country
has lost stupidly trillions of dollars
with China over many years they have
stolen our intellectual property at a
rate of hundreds of billions of dollars
a year and they want to continue I won't
let that happen
we don't need China and frankly would be
far better off without them the vast
amounts of money made and stolen by
China from the United States year after
year for decades will and must stop
here's a key part our great American
companies are hereby ordered to
immediately start looking for an
alternative to China including bringing
your companies home and making your
products in the USA okay it goes on from
there the key part is American companies
are hereby ordered to immediately look
for alternatives to China what does that
mean it's completely perplexing from a
legal point of view first of all as a
tweet does it count as a policy is it a
formal directive the consensus is no it
doesn't but it still sounds official
when you see the president saying the
companies are hereby ordered but as a
tweet alone it is not law or a formal
directive in and of itself but then the
question is is that something Donald
Trump is going to do what is the legal
basis for ordering companies to not deal
with China is this some kind of de facto
sanctions
without actually putting in place
sanctions is he threatening to put in
place those real types of sanctions
which would be just an implosive act
when it comes to the American economy
which I'll explain in more detail
momentarily this is the type of thing
that actually happens in fascist
dictatorships it's the sort of mob style
authoritarian national politic and then
income the tariffs once again escalating
these back and forth retaliatory tariffs
from China on the US and from the US on
China to our detriment October 1 tariffs
on two hundred and fifty billion in
imports go from 25 to 30 percent
destructive September 1 three hundred
billion dollars will be taxed at 15
percent instead of 10 percent understand
there is no off-ramp here this is
crushing farmers this is bad for
builders this is bad for all sorts of
everyday Americans we are told that
eventually these tariffs will be so
destructive to China that China will
cave and come to trump begging and
pleading and trump's going to win and
everybody's going to be happy it's not
going to happen
understand that a ton of the stuff that
we sell to China they can get elsewhere
or they can make themselves they're
already turning to other countries for
some building materials they're making
energy deals with Russia the things we
get from China would be way more
expensive to either make here or get
elsewhere we don't have the leverage
this is not a political analysis this is
an economic reality this is sort of like
a mob dispute except here one side has
no leverage but doesn't get it in the
mob oftentimes they know when they're
beat they know when they don't have
leverage and they adjust their behavior
Trump's behaving like a mob boss with
leverage but he doesn't have it and
we're increasingly out in this triangle
of the world's superpowers China Russia
and the US China and Russia increasingly
working together more and more while the
United States is ignored and out and
self-destructing with Donald Trump's
trade policy no one is denying that
China has a human rights issue no one is
denying that they
are doing horrible things when it comes
to intellectual property but this is
just the logistical reality they can
bounce back from this trade war way more
easily than we can the markets are
seeing it we do not have the leverage
and Trump ignores that we have a trade
deficit with China for a reason this is
like a fundamental misunderstanding
Trump says look at our trade deficit
with China we import from them much more
than we export that's the definition of
a trade deficit that's a sign that we
are losing to China we designed our
economy to have a trade deficit with
China what I mean is we can import tons
of cheap stuff from them and it's good
for our economy in a particular way but
there's good and bad to all of these
arrangements this type of situation has
winners and losers in different ways but
Republicans and Democrats both wanted a
trade deficit even if they didn't say we
want a trade deficit in that the whole
point was let's get a bunch of stuff
from China because it's so cheap and
then we can make it available into in
the United States to people at far lower
costs than they would be if we were to
manufacture ourselves or in higher cost
of production countries Republicans and
Democrats both wanted it we knew that it
would have a jobs cost and it has and
that's a perfectly reasonable debate to
have but Donald Trump doesn't understand
that Donald Trump doesn't have an
off-ramp from the from the trade from
the tariffs the trade war Donald Trump
doesn't understand that we have a trade
deficit for a reason it's not just China
is winning or China has this over a
barrel and sadly Trump's ignorant base
never got it when Trump bragged about
his expertise when it comes to trade
they still don't get it
and they'll probably still vote to
re-elect the guy in 2020
but this is the reality the markets are
suffering every day people are suffering
farmers are suffering people that work
for home builders are suffering and
Trump doesn't even seem to have the
capacity to understand the mechanics
behind it let me know what you think I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show and make
sure you follow me on Twitch at twitch
TV slash David Pakman at least a couple
of live streams happening this week on
twitch